If you remember.
from our last session we talked about
the multi-- the perceptron
it was this mathematical model.
Where we had these features?
and with each feature was associated with
let me actually pull the pull that up. If you
remember we showed we talked about this very fundamental component of
a neural network.
So it has
you know.
these inputs
and each input corresponds to
a feature of the data set
So again to use a real estate example the features of a
property.
It's the number of bedrooms the number of
bathrooms.
the size of the apartment
And these are the weights now in machine
learning terminology you we also
called these.
parameters
So weights parameters, these are the same thing.
Parameters and weights refer to the same thing.
So here
the purpose of the training data set
is to let the model learn the parameters to understand.
To understand, you know, it's all.
statistical calculation
but we want the monitor calculate the weights. Now if
you have a regression problem the way you find the weights.
Will you there's something called the Computing formula?
Again, it's nothing more than basic arithmetic.
Maybe we can talk about the later on.
But it has to do with the observations and the residuals.
And the residual is a distance of the observation from
the regression line. If you've watched the video from
that, I referenced you would
be familiar with these terms anyway in the training stage.
We want the model to learn the parameters.
Sometimes training in validation is done in one.
in one go
So depending on the library that you're using in the machine
learning while they're using you may have to create you may need to
have three divisions. So you will take your original data and
divide it three.
Training validation tests other times you can just have trained and
test.
the purpose of validation
is to see the check the metrics to identify underfitting
overfitting.
We said that underfing underfitting is when the
model has not been able to calculate the
weights properly and you can easily detect this
because as soon as you look at the metrics
Let's say we talked about MSC if the MSC is large.
It is diverging from zero for the
trading at the side. That's under 30.
So we don't go any further. We don't even proceed to test.
So if that happens.
then
we'd have to adjust our data or adjust our
machine learning model.
And that is if we can even do something about it
because sometimes the data so sparse so.
Unusable, there's not much you can do about it.
You know the same garbage in garbage out.
So we need to make sure there's no garbage.
but
another purpose of validation is for the model to
Just a parameters afterwards has learned.
So after it learns the parameters.
Even if the metrics are good, let's
say MSC is good.
We want it to be better still.
So in this validation stage
with the validation data set.
We can we look at the metrics and then if necessary
we up. We change the hyper parameters now do not.
Conflate parameters in hyper parameters. Unfortunately, there's one
library at least that I S skater very popular Library.
They use these two words interchangeably or
at least when I look at the documentation that of the case that's a
problem because
hyper parameter parameters are different things very different
things. The parameters are the weights that the
model must learn.
the hyperparameters
Are like the arguments of the
function?
so we will have
let's see a machine learning class like sequential and
the sequential class can take different arguments. We
will see this in a minute.
You as the data sites must choose the hyper parameters.
They're effectively arguments of a function. So you must change the
architecture of the neural network. If in
the case of deep learning until you get a better combination, so
as the machine learning if you're doing machine under two things you
need to fix.
Or two things need to take into account the date the
quality of the data.
and the type of machine learning model, you've
choose you've chosen and the
The configuration so actually that's
a better word for hyperprem is the configuration.
hyperparameters equals configuration of the model
now
In order for you to find out.
if this model
is
usable and can be put into production
after the best possible.
configuration after the best possible data
mudging that imagining is nobody clean the data.
You do feature engineering. So assuming you've done you've picked
the best possible model and you have so you have
produced the best possible data if this
model is going to be useful or not, and that is used to test data set.
the test data set
after test essay will check the metrics after the adjusted model
after the adjusted parameter after the model has learned the new
parameters.
So after the test data set your metrics are still poor then.
The model is not the it's not the right option. That is
assuming your data is
you know well
You know, your data is in the best possible condition.
So if that's the if that's the case and your model
is still pulled and you need to choose a different model. Either that or
again you need to check the hyper parameters. So if you find over
a fitting here.
Then you must go back.
to
what comes before the training stage?
Okay.
So in our case, we just need training test.
The training that is that would allow them all to learn the parameters. And
the test said I said we will see if we have underfitting overfitting.
Or if we are on the right track.